[Music]
hi guys how are you doing
so this week we had a lot of interesting
games and tournaments happen but one of
my favorite ones was the things that was
happening in well kind of like last year
Liam around these times so I'm gonna do
doubts instead of this week's game so
last year this week's game Maya that my
problem is like whenever I'm trying to
do a game and I go look at it they're
like everybody like so like everybody
right now every tournament is online so
everybody is going and looking at the
games and analyzing it and you can find
like five different channels and
broadcasters were all like at the same
time analyzing the game so I tried I'll
do this week's game this first of the
July week's game but from last year so
why not alright so I wanted to show this
game that is actually very interesting
I'm a big fan of Yvonne chick so I like
his game because the style he's a very
very talented chess player so let's jump
in this is the position that I wanted to
nope that's not the position this is a
game that I wanted to get to and so I
also want to ask who here plays this
type of opening with white like the
Knight f3 then like d4 just like the d4
style opening because these are a lot of
interesting ideas that you guys could
follow for me I don't play this as black
like I play d4 the nimzo-indian
grünfeld King's Indian like a whole mix
of those but not d5 anymore so I don't
really gets into the Queens gambit
declined or accepted so yeah just wanted
to get some eye
on basically was popping all right so
this is a very interesting idea and so
after Queen a for some of the moves that
could be things that you could think
about or maybe Bishop d7 maybe 96 but c6
b5 is one of the oldest ideas in the
book and I think this is something that
I've actually played to with black
because it can transpose from name is o
Indian - alright so right now there are
like queen bee trees I think there's
clean d3 and there are other lines that
if the night is back on b1 and the pawn
is on g3 there is Queen c2 similar
positions so there's a lot of
similarities among these positions so
now let's say Queen goes to b3 and 97
makes sense right you want to develop g3
now black plays this Bishop p7 and yes
King Lear you're correct this is a semi
Slav well kind of yeah I could have been
with like Bishop g5 h6 stuff so yeah now
white goes Bishop g2 normal stuff still
normally developing so first question
black zoom what do you think will black
should play right now
so black to move oh if you were black
what would you want to do exactly thank
you Asics so instance has a very
interesting idea because well after
whoops
well after a six we are just protecting
v5 and kind of preparing for c5 right
alright so after a six did the ideas c5
now here you want your plate 95 which is
also a just normal great idea
also stopping c5 right we're also
putting more pressure on the c6 pawn so
after 95 Queen c8 makes sense right now
you want to play c5 white castles black
plays c5 and now what do you think white
should play do you think we should take
on v7 do you think we should take on d7
do you think we should just let it be
I think I also forgot to say who was
black this game was played between a von
Schuch and I think it was necessary Nia
Nia serene and this was last year in
Lyon Masters yeah there we go thank you
have a good time you been
and the interesting thing is that the
same tournament the Lyon Masters is
gonna happen again
mmm starting June 10 July 10th
so basically tomorrow yeah so that's
another interesting I didn't think
that's kind of like overlaps and good
stuff so 97 is an interesting idea and
97 I think was actually a novelty from
my understanding yeah so 97 is something
that never has really been played before
or at least in higher-level so Bishop e7
is something that previously was played
and Bishop e7 take now we can take over
there take over there
t5 c4 and this was a game with Dane
Sarkissian and Gelfand I'm also a big
fan of girlfriend he's a great chess
player I really enjoyed his books and
also the recipes at the end of the books
I gave it a fair try so this was a game
that's what happened and that's this
position is what happened in that game
to Circassian girlfriend but we are
looking for this novelty here I have a
knight takes t7 so 97 Queen has to take
right now Bishop takes take we take on
c5 and this is a very interesting
position now it could do this Bishop g5
and now we can kind of understand why
this was the idea of the semi Slav
glenda move 5 Bishop g5 so
yeah this is something that's it's worth
looking at all right so I also so let's
say castle and I want to leave you in
this position
and ask you what should White's do so
what you guys are thinking I also want
to kind of talk about something and get
some opinions so if like a move such as
an I don't move that we just one night
xt7 which shows a novelty let's say and
like a lower rated player much lower
rated players players but not because
it's preparation just because it looks
good
and so now does that mean that in the 97
that the super Grandmaster won't replace
is it not a novelty anymore or does it
mean that it's just because someone else
someone much lower level played it so
that's something that I've been debating
with some of my chest friends love us
just because someone else played it but
they didn't really know what they were
doing does it mean this is not a novelty
anymore so yeah here's some fruit for
thoughts to sit and debate about all
right so now why to move what do you
guys want to do do you guys want to eat
anything exchange anything develop
anything push some pawns I think those
would I think those are the options
basically well the chat is so quiet
right now all right we want to grab the
open D file
all right so thank you for your ideas
about this novel to debate yet one of
the one of the points of views was like
when when someone click figures out it's
like finds a new land it doesn't matter
if they were looking for as if or if
they actually like just found it by
accident so that was a that was one of
the things that was in the debate like
in favor of whoever finds it first I
guess that's the Finders Keepers rule
anyways so we're talking about some of
the ideas that are in the chapter a for
oops not that one yet rook t1 or um
thank you sigh but legal moves let's
let's talk about legal moves alright so
I think those are interesting ideas but
why isn't anybody talking about Bishop
takes f6 Bishop things that takes a
great idea thank you yeah I just got
someone saying it's great big ass Bishop
takes f6 you gotta take it back right
and now this pawn structure is beginning
to get a little smelly now we play this
trick d1 now why don't you move what do
you want to do do you want to exchange
those rooks do you wanna
[Music]
well maybe play a four
hmm
ever was like a trick question sorry I
meant to trick you
hey four is doable but not really ideal
because of p4 and the problem is like
well now what do you want to do with
your night if you go to eight you that's
that's once at night if you play
something like III and ignore the fact
that you're not under attack then Queen
can come to f3 whoa there we go so yes I
am glad so many people are falling for
my little trap
and going for a for a for is not the
best move before isn't I mean it's a
doable move it's not like it's a blunder
but a for could give so much opportunity
to your opponent so whoever was thinking
about taking taking over the D file
that's the right idea take take rook d1
that's the best best way to go about it
now if they take you just take dominance
of this file but if they don't take you
can also just choke now you are you
brought attention now you can wait and
see who breaks first basically so now
what's blacks biggest threats f2 right
so let's play F III and stop these
threats
so now why - what just played III black
to move what do you think I should do
do you see any way for black to advance
his position any ideas any threats it is
black to move we just played III so for
those of you who are not familiar with
options outcome port works if there is
this highlight that means we just did to
move so we can't play 94 hmm well I'm
not saying this is a promising position
for light but it's a very playable
position for both sides right now I
think this is just a fight you're just
fighting to see who has more skills to
transform this position to a promising
position so III I see a lot of ideas
with before those are interesting ideas
but you have something much more
interesting that no one has mentioned so
far King g7 is doable yeah but something
even a little bit stronger so I'm not
the biggest fan of ePHI just because if
you play e5 d v square is completely
well ready for tonight
whoops not like nah all right there's 95
possible there's rectify possible then
Queen d1 so sorry when I said the D
class was ready for not just any piece
so all right I did see a 5 in chat so
I'm going to assume that it's well
thought so f5 now f5 now what do you
want to do let's say after this f5
whites to move what do you want to do do
you wanna exchange these districts do
you want to relocate the night somewhere
better
what ah not that
all right so f5
why Tim
kingi to change it doesn't make much
sense to me what if King J - I just give
you check and you have to play King g1
again I mean it's not like the worst
thing that you could do but it doesn't
make sense just Rick t7 and I'm just
holding yep 92 to f4 yeah that's a good
idea
92 now let's say after nighty to black
play something like Bishop e7 what I was
thinking about was maybe Bishop d6 to
avoid exchanging works but then there's
like a four before Queen c4 yeah it's a
it's not the easiest position to play I
agree with you guys
alright so Bishop e7 now why team what
should you do should you exchange those
rooks and try your chances in the end
King with like the Queen and Bishop
Queen and Bishop versus queen tonight
I think Rick t3 is also an interesting
idea yeah because you just want to pull
your Queen d1 whoops where's the rest of
my hair no that's nice there we go yeah
I think this is an interesting idea to
play and get the Queen behind the rock
but what if just like Queen goes to c7
Queen d1 now just take take
can I just exchange Queens so another
question do you think right now move
such as Queen d6 is better for white or
black
I think it's about I think that's about
equal honestly so it's not really as
easy it's not that easy to just say yeah
here is why it's watch way better just
after exchanging exchanging cleans or
not so I think if teacher is a valid
point but in the game of rook th was
played take Queen c2 so basically I
think the idea is you have this file I'm
gonna have this file for now I think
that's just the idea for right now and
it's a good file to have you can easily
could have an I in the Kings side and
sorry Queen side and you can't really do
much in the Kings side right now anyway
so you might as well keep your focus on
the Queen side all right so Queen c2
Bishop f6 not before I think before if
you're telling me provides before right
now would be a little too hasty mmm
you never know when you actually need
these palms so something like b3 would
make a little bit more sense just
thinking about future and after b3 now
in the game black played Bishop e5 so
now what do you think white should do do
you see any interesting maneuvers or
ideas for white
sure what do you think I should do
efore um I don't know if four is the
best idea just because if you and you
play efore well it would if take take
hmm now I was thinking it was clean d5
but no this is just a so even okay let
me let me try and explain something even
though this position looks very boring
and very little to do little maneuvering
to do little ideas to have you still
have to play it tricky if you will efore
take take Queen d5 it is just it's you
might as well just offer as you're all
right now so if you're playing and if
you're fighting yeah I think it's a
better idea to keep keep the chances for
your opponent to make a mistake
so yes 91 91 would be more interesting
getting a knight talk to d3 and now so
in the game right now
it won't choke plate h4 do you think
that's a good move if no then why yeah
that's a good idea this light versus the
special the kind of like kind of a tied
up this pond could be weak if this pawn
gets up to h6 that's ideal what else
there's a question why not before I
think before the thing is a check if
King g7 well I'll just pick that up
but if you play like Bishop f8 so can I
just take before or I can pick this up
or that so the idea of h4 was not just
to play just a queen seat but that's
also a big part of it so h4 let's say
black just plays I'm just gonna play a
weird move push of a three now do you
think queen seat is possible well not
anymore because Bishop have faith and
you can't take that because d3 is
falling but um mmm what I was trying to
say say was if King goes to g7 now I
actually it's getting interesting now
before this guy so I was just showing
you something like if black plays just
just to move and nothing that accurate
why it still has a lot of traps on the
position so yeah exactly
h4 also it's a like a prophet lacks a
move so black best black actually in the
game played h5 I'm not gonna say best
move because it's not the best move it's
just like a doable move white black
would play like a five black would play
King g7 I think black would even
consider from the e5 okay maybe hold on
not right now because there's chicken
take oops but when there's not check and
take when there's like let's say King g7
knocking g7 let's say we also play like
King f1 now e5 no more check and take so
I think this is a this is an interesting
position for
walk right now so let's go back h4 h5
now if I wasn't the most accurate move
anyone want to take a swing at it
and tell me why it's not the most
accurate move
hmm I don't think it's about the king I
think the way we could look at it is
just like no so h5 is not a bad mood was
just not the most accurate like
something like King g7 with the idea if
I would be more accurate but we didn't
do that now and so now white can
actually play something just like King
f1 so the another idea that we put h4
was to free this pawn so there won't be
like some check and take and we may we
could try and get the King in the closer
closer
to protect them light so we free the the
Queen knows a long sentence so does that
make sense we played this aged 4 to free
this King from having to protect upon so
when this pawn is in a good place we
bring the King come defend this look I
and we free the Queen from having to
defend it so far so good
all right so my point is that things so
my point is that white has like this
clear plan whereas something like h5
doesn't really go with the flow of the
game so in the game black poet just King
g7 Chingy - and here we got this
interesting 'if I've happened finally
now white just played Queen c3 simple
ideas just we don't really want to have
this e 4 F 4 happened so let's just stop
it so Queen C 3 King gauge 7 in the game
white played 91 I think the idea is
pretty simple you just want to keep you
just want to keep your position stable
and see if black will make a mistake I
think this is something that
psychologically happens a lot - like
when there is a huge age difference like
this adventure was playing near Houston
Whitney Houston is a teenager it one
trick is well not a teenager so I think
that's that's a big thing that
I think here also a von Schuch was
testing Wow Nelson's patience to see how
patient is kid is how can he manage
under a lot of pressure and having this
so many ponds that are kind of just
wobbly I've had stuff like this and it's
not really pleasant so it is
understandable to make a mistake so I've
said all of these because I'm kind of
laying the ground to say that here black
made a mistake but what do you think is
the best move for black
so blackton what do you think is the
best move
hmm no II for efore I understand
efore but II for is not really nice let
me let me let me ask you guys to do this
if you're just giving me a move for
black make sure to at least give me what
you think whites will respond so I'm
saying I'm saying a lot of ephors air
force befores make sure to tell me what
should whites do like before what I
think is the most annoying move that
white can play maybe night see two Bobby
Knights g2 who knows
so just tell me which one I thank you
mama before yeah I think II for night c2
is reasonable efore I think also maybe
Queen d4 or maybe just night c2 first
and then Knight can go to d4 yeah I
think if R is interesting but just nice
kind of just gets up there so I've seen
alright thank you for sharing the idea
before yeah before you're right Queen
dieter is the best move take take and
now actually this is a better endgame
for white because the king is way too
close and we are just gonna start
attacking all these pawns
so Queen d3 also you're gonna have to
take it because if you don't then you're
losing this pawn or this pawn so let's
go back so before not a good move efore
is possible but not really and
I just said before queen d3 attacking
all the pants and the endgame after the
coins are exchanged is better for whites
so right now black to move we've talked
about efore it's okay move before it's a
not okay move we are gonna talk about f
for a two but I was kind of hoping
someone would say the best move or like
one of the good moves before we look
into what happens in the game so in the
game the f4 happened that f4 gives white
a lot of chances not because of G takes
f 4 because of Queens T to check so
let's I want to show you the Bishop c5
idea to Bishop c5 isn't one of those
moves that also holding because now what
are you gonna do with your night if
Knight d3 alright I'll just play Bishop
d6 if you play Knight C - well alright I
will just play Kinder's play Bishop e7
or can I now play efore yeah I think
these are just I mean very normal moves
all right um so a form is played Queen
c2 King g7 now why to move how can white
improve her the position make black just
made a mistake we use this mistake now
how can we improve it how can we keep
using this mistake what did the move f4
change the mover for K was the diagonal
of h7 b1 so how can we use that also I
just remembered I had well I had some
games but one game that comes to my mind
right away about when I broke under
pressure to the to higher and older
opponent higher rated older opponents
and I'm not sure that later on not today
but another time so yeah it was kind of
it was a sad came for me I was actually
thinking about showing that today before
this class but yeah we'll talk about
the psychological pressures later on as
well all right so yes Queen a5 thank you
for everybody who participated and yes
Queen a5 is the best idea because after
Queen f5 you are talking so many things
you are attacking this for h5 you're
attacking potential taking on here and
what should black - I think maybe
Queenie six might be the best chance
maybe but what if I just take and now
just see for now this is a weak bond
just king up the night here by wipe-on
if you take I take back and now this is
a bad Bishop because this Bishop always
has to stay here we can just even put
this night here also there is pawn
majority so yeah this would be also a
sad end game for a black so here after
Queen a5 take happen in the game we take
back and here Bishop b4 some ideas right
now black has some ideas with potential
Queen dichos all right
white remove what should we do you want
to ignore this Queen d2 idea and give
bunch of checks or do you wanna close up
with maybe 93 or Dark Knight f3
I asked idea Knight f3 more cuz if my d3
there could be some queen G twos
potentially and then take on g3 who is
black Nihal Syrian there sorry
alright so Knight to f3 is the best
choice to go for and after Knight f3 we
are attacking a 5 and h5 so actually in
the game finally I saw there was only
have 6 in the chat and finally f6
happened so now can you guys find the
best move for white and don't forget you
give me move for white don't forget to
give something for a black to just as a
2-way game can't expect to make a move
when your opponent doesn't make a move
all right
um
all right I see the idea of a g4 I think
that's a cool idea g4 maybe yeah so I
don't like efore be easy because efore
is kind of sorry the problem with oh
come on
efore is that clean can just go to c5
and then this your king is way exposed
right now and the next move Queen c2 can
come this Bishop becomes a kind of like
monster we can go in more depth if you
want to but it's kind of clear before is
kind of allowing opponent to step away
so g4 is the best move the thing is well
if take now we just take with the Queen
and depending on where the King goes
like if you play King your fight well I
mean you just losing this right didn't
really depend on where the king goes I
was thinking if there is any meat but I
was kind of thinking about h5 but that's
kind of a I mean this is possible too
but we can't just eat the piece so here
dr. g4 in the game they all just play
the queen of seven I think yeah
Queen f7 and now we just pick up a pawn
so in this position now if one trick is
much better right we just have to he
just have to the play kind of really
accurate and now it's really um you know
mess it up so taking on h5 in the game
he went with Bishop e7 I think I mean
bishops teacher is also doable but if
bishops III just I mean 92 and maybe
just 94 and h6 is what's happening
so take Bishop e7 what the white to move
what to do
yep nine touch - you're just going to
Eve - g4 and that should be pretty
plenty so night h2 King edge 894 also
going after this little guy after Queen
d5 now the game is kind of starting to
wrap up so Queen d5 well what do you
think white should do what do you think
it's why it's best move
yeah all right I see I see a lot of nice
ideas and H things is just a simplest
way to win because after h6
now walk you can't really just black
can't really do anything Knight f6 is
interesting but what if Queen just goes
to Epsilon you kinda have to give this
check only move to keep the night and
now the night has to move away
maybe nighttime their King age 7
maybe another check King gauge 6 now it
just feels like it's kind of running
away and now it's 5 is falling it's 4 is
weak
yeah I don't like this the whole idea
that we've had so far the idea was to
put pressure and we don't really want to
lose that pressure just because right
now it's well kind of 96 would allow
black to kind of create brittle little
all right so h6 is the best idea
Queen G to check Knights F to cover up
and here he was clean d5 which was a bad
move but I mean honestly here like white
is watch much better and just this is
also much better but he let her clean d5
so now can you guys find the best move
for whites right now
mmm clean g6 is interesting but do you
have something stronger
h7 also doable but not I mean honestly I
hold on Queen h6
a Quincy six is also I think best LAN
just going after mates and it fish up
there just queen g6 queen of 60 I think
this was actually much stronger but
another move that could be played its h5
and the idea of each mine was pretty
pretty simple
h5 I want to be able to well push the
pond honestly and h5 now next move I do
this Queen g6 but I think when g6 or all
the air was just as good so I mean I
don't really see why h5 first I think it
was just more pressure
Bishop f8 h 7 now I've got going after
g8 now Knight g4 going after this one I
think one of the big things about having
h4 was if Bishop g7 now just h6 so this
was the first game that I wanted to show
you I was kind of hoping it's with
running a little faster so I would have
more time on the next game but it's ok
we still have time to go over next game
too but I just have to might have to do
it a little bit faster
alright let me switch the boards real
fast this is another game of event trick
too so you can see that I'm a fan but in
this game well not surprisingly this
game was between a von Schuch and the
Iranian Maqsood Lu Perham I know that
when he was a kid so I don't really I'm
not really biased it was just really a
good game so I'm gonna kind of go a
little too fast on this parts the
opening part so we have more time to
focus on the middle game because the
middle game was actually really
beautiful so this was in the same
tournament I think it was a last round
I think it was the last round but I
might be wrong so feel free to correct
me
I take criticism quite well more than I
should
all right so this is just a classic
rouser game everything going well
actually I had a game like this today in
the twitch channel f4 is actually the
way most people play like I actually
played it for two but I kind of wanted
to I mean he kind of went with f3 and
went about it this way so this is a good
idea why it's doing good Blackston good
rouser is a very sharp very sharp
opening so after this position I finally
reached one of the critical positions
that there could be h4 they could be
Bishop e3 but paramount play it once
you're quite king big one so after king
b1 finally we have opposites coloured
opposite side whoa Castle opposite color
to Castle they'll be interesting huh all
right so in this position Bishop e3 is
interesting I think Bishop e3 was
actually a really interesting move well
there's this thing like 94 could be
coming up eventually so that could be
one reason but after short Castle this
is not this doesn't really like strike
me as 94 style
so after h4 I think h4 is s 4 is more
common honestly because you want to
start attacking on the Kings side and
like h4 b5 that's like the common style
but it's Bishop e3 I understand Bishop
e3 as well you're just protecting your
Bishop a little bit better before you
start attacking so Bishop e3 b5 now
g4 take take take
I mean Bishop c6 and another idea to
think about is when to put the rook on
c8 so that's not one of the big
questions that's I also kind of have to
understand better for myself is when to
actually put these rooks to c8 and b8
went to start pushing these pawns
because I was thinking if we can just
start playing before now and if the
knight goes to e 2 maybe let's get the
Queen to a5 mid let's bring the other
rook to see a tour b8 that's kind of I
like that was kind of what I was
thinking about but a bishop c6 also does
make perfect sense paralyzes the ideas
that f4 has a good eye on the center so
in the game after Bishop c6g 597 so far
everything logical you attack my Kings
side I attack your queen side or
basically attack my king i attack your
king and right now blocked by d5 do you
think t5 is a good move
mmm defenders okay move but it's not
yeah exactly a little premature thank
you
so this problem with d5 is a five and
it's kind of like starts closing center
so you were very committed to the attack
now I think that's kind of what scares
me a little
like if tank all right technique is good
I take with the bishop my bishop is very
strong good-looking after that a to the
pond before kick the night away so I can
understand this and I like this idea but
II five was the move that kind of a
little I wasn't really the biggest fan
of so ii v a5 and finally oh I was right
little man sir there we go so II 585 and
now after and move such as white place
at four I'm gonna ask you guys what do
you think black should do
ah
all right I'm getting a lot of b-trees
some f5 so alright some eight fours yeah
84 is I'm sorry hold on I wanted to talk
yeah
84 is actually a doable move but a four
I'm a little worried about like
something g6 right away or maybe h5 10
g6
it kind of feels like whites doing a
little bit faster than black is so
that's that's what worries me
and there were some other suggestion
about Knight f4 but after nights before
black would simply play something like
night c5 again probably maybe if Knight
f4 hopefully not c5 no 95 doesn't work
anymore sorry cuz h5 and this is a
little too fast I can't so you take over
here because of their so yeah 95 is a
bad don't do 95 but we could simply play
potential just a for now because this
night is on f4 and not protecting this
so h5 k is not as a scary now this is
becoming this is falling all right let's
go back to f4 and now we can try playing
Knight c5 finally so the idea of 95 is a
pretty simple again a 4 as possible but
tonight tonight c5 kind of makes a
little bit more sense because you are
heading for here efore or maybe a 4 but
e for maybe a little bit more maybe
towards a Ford so in the game even trick
played Queen e3 we got this 94 and
finally white players tries to develop
this push up I mean I ideally I want
this Bishop to be like d3 but
I mean it's well you can't always get
what you want so dish of a stream
something like my g3 makes a lot of
sense to me too because if not g3 is you
play something like take now it's
actually good
just queen takes the queen is behind the
pawns and this pawn march is very strong
so if you don't take you could play
something like a four and knavish five
this is still makes more sense to me
Knight g3 then maybe wish I wish tree
but Bishop Street is also in threads
with five so pushed up a stream now
finally Bishop d7 the idea of Bishop d7
is to simply stop this f5 and to well
you're probably trying to stop your
opponent's attack while promoting your
own and that is exactly what white is
doing - now what - Bishop g2 so now
again the rook is open attacking a fort
and trying to pick up a pawn so once a
white just play Bishop g2 black to move
what do you think you should do it black
nice e-5 not sure then I see five it's a
kind of a blunder just take it all right
so Bishop back to c6 not really we still
want to fight a for no because we do you
still have to develop your queen on your
roof or at least you're clean before oh
thank you
Beltrami all right Queen c7 we kind of
need to get the queen up before we can
start pushing anymore so let's say that
we encounter this take taking on e for
NASA blunder because of Bishop c6 but we
can play 93 to go after E for right so
93 now black can simply try and continue
developing with Rick c8 going after C -
Lucas - threatening to take Quinn take
c4 finally a for Knight takes e4 now
black to move what do you think we
should do with these pawns all of your
pieces seem to be ready to break through
and make some final attack right but how
yes exactly beat whoa no give up the
ending no you guys wouldn't see it ah ah
man it's the one thing I do wrong with
Chester's comments when I actually miss
click oh man all right let's go back a
little my enthusiasm level just went all
right you are correct about d3 ah
all right well b3 in the game we want
your took C takes b3 but if not bishops
III was the black more solid option
Bishop c3 holds to hold everything
together now if you take on a - I don't
play King a1 a3 now b3 kind of
everything gets stuck together if you
take on Bishop c3 if you take likes
there I'll just take it back with the
rook and that's also why it's holding
well so it's alright so most of the time
it's highly unlikely that taking back
the pandas attacking you like this be
three pawns is g 6 pawns it's most of
the times it's not a good idea so just
have that in mind and try not to you
know make your opponent's life much
easier
so after b3 c b3 we take back now this
is well now this is a serious threat
we're also taking with the rook right
so after seat takes after it takes b3 a
throw is pretty much the only move to do
right so now my question to you is how
can black try and push a little bit more
in this position probably have to throw
in a queen somewhere bring the bishop
somewhere you gotta bring stuff right
Bishop before maybe look too early okay
tree oh boy no no way too early first
stuff like that
Bishop c6 is the best move going after
this night putting the bishop on d5 this
is a good pun you don't want to I mean
you don't necessarily you want to give
it up you could put the oops you could
put a bishop there to look after it
alright Bishop c6 so Bishop c6 rook d2
now finally we play this rook a port
okay for it's also a great move one
thing I wanted to mention is of h5 we
can just take on e4 and if take back Dan
rook a4 also pinning this guy so rook t2
rook a for now in the game
white white knight c3 you can already
see why it's attack is kind of stopped
because has to bring pieces to defend
his king right so nice c3 black to move
what should we do we should save this
rook somehow right so where do you think
is the best square to go
mmm-hmm good job Brooksie for Recife is
pretty strong you are well bringing it
to the open file and you're also
threatening to have some bishop ephors
happen eventually
so in the game white played a file which
was a mistake because just take and now
there is even more support for Bishop a4
a6
finally Bishop before you can't take it
because of a lack c1 and oops mate and
in the game why it's just but laughter
bishop before white just played King a1
now this is a super strong diagonal that
black has and should already be giving
you some stuff to want to do to this
King so what do you want to do to this
King
ideal you want to be able to stock
something in a - yeah exactly so in the
game first of all the background check
on e6 because well this is a this is a
knowing pawn and also there you don't
really want to give your opponent some
chances to train run away but anyway
something like Queen 85 is also just as
good so we take this guy and this was
like a desperate try honestly because
yes it is possible to take and rook d7
and just play Knight rook c3 this is
also winning Luke c7 rook c7 this is
also again winning but you don't really
need to do this kind of stuff you can
just after Bishop g7 I can ignore it and
play Queen e5 now you want to play
Bishop e3 right so in the game after
Bishop f6 hmm we finally did this take
on a tree and now this is super winning
let's say rook d8 someone tell me how
the last move of the game we got this
rook the eight what should black two
black to move here under check but also
keep in mind that there is a weak King
over there yep this will fit you start
setting up for the next game while
giving your opponent check and kind of
forced mate and yeah this was one of
those beautiful games I really like this
game was a most kind of a very
interesting game anyways and yeah so I
hope you guys enjoyed two of this week's
game from last year and hopefully by
next week we'll have something a little
bit more up-to-date
oh yeah the Leone again but everybody
else will be doing it anyways so good
luck for me and this was fun I hope you
guys learned a lot from it and have a
good rest of your night
[Applause]
you
[Music]